digamos que tenemos una reacción de
orden cero en la que el reactivo y se
transforma en los productos y cuando el
tiempo es igual a cero estamos empezando
con esta concentración inicial de a y
después de un tiempo t tenemos una
concentración de a gente menor y ahora
si queremos expresar la velocidad de la
reacción
tenemos dos formas una de ellas es tomar
la velocidad promedio velocidad promedio
que es igual a menos el incremento en la
concentración de a
entre el incremento en el tiempo
ok esta es la velocidad promedio en este
intervalo de tiempo pero por otro lado
también podemos escribir por aquí la
velocidad instantánea de esta reacción
utilizando la ley de la velocidad la
es igual a la constante de velocidad de
la reacción por la concentración de a y
como es una reacción de orden cero
entonces esta concentración va elevada a
la cero pero cualquier número elevado a
la cero es simplemente un 1 entonces
esto se reduce a que la velocidad
instantánea de la reacción es igual a la
constante de velocidad porque la
velocidad de una reacción de orden cero
es una constante es independiente de la
concentración de a y por otro lado de la
velocidad promedio podemos sacar la
velocidad instantánea utilizando las
derivadas
y aquí podemos obtener que la velocidad
instantánea es igual a menos la derivada
de la concentración de a con respecto al
tiempo y como aquí tenemos dos
velocidades instantáneas podemos igualar
estos dos entonces tenemos que menos la
derivada de la concentración de a con
respecto al tiempo es igual a la
constante de velocidad de la reacción
aunque y también lo podemos escribir
como que la velocidad de cambio de la
concentración de a es igual a menos la
constante de velocidad por la velocidad
de cambio en el tiempo y entonces ya
estamos listos para integrar hoy vamos a
integrar esto de aquí y por acá como acá
es una constante la podemos de una vez
sacar de la integral ok
y tenemos que regresar arriba para
encontrar los límites de integración
como podemos ver aquí queremos integrar
desde que el tiempo es igual a cero
hasta que el tiempo es igual a t y en
términos de la concentración de a esto
es igual a integrar desde la
concentración inicial de a hasta la
concentración de a al tiempo que
entonces regresamos otra vez estamos
integrando el tiempo desde cero hasta t
y estamos integrando con respecto a la
concentración de a desde la
concentración inicial de a hasta la
concentración de a al tiempo t y estas
integrales están súper sencillas porque
la integral de 1 con respecto a la
concentración de a es simplemente la
concentración de a y nada más la tenemos
que evaluar desde la concentración
inicial de a hasta la concentración de a
al tiempo t
es igual a igual a menos que por la
integral de 0 a t con respecto a 3 o sea
te evaluado desde cero hasta entonces
evaluamos esta cosa de aquí y nos queda
la concentración de gente menos la
concentración inicial de a y eso igual a
menos que por de menos 0 o sea
simplemente t y esto de aquí ya es una
forma de la ley de la velocidad
integrada para reacciones de orden cero
pero por supuesto lo podemos modificar
un poco podemos pasar la concentración
inicial de a del lado derecho y lo que
nos queda entonces es que la
concentración de a al tiempo t es igual
a menos que te más la concentración
inicial de a
y esta es otra forma de escribir la ley
de la velocidad integrada para
reacciones de orden cero y como podemos
ver esto está escrito en la forma de una
recta que era la forma de igual a m x
más bien y entonces si hacemos una
gráfica en la que pongamos en el eje x
al tiempo que vamos a poner al tiempo en
el eje x y en el eje y ponemos a la
concentración de al tiempo t entonces
estamos graficando la concentración de
al tiempo t con respecto al tiempo lo
que vamos a obtener es una línea recta
cuya pendiente es menos la constante de
velocidad de la reacción y la ordenada
al origen de esa recta es la
concentración inicial de a así es
si colocamos por aquí un par de ejes
y ponemos en el eje de las x el tiempo y
en el eje de la siesta la concentración
del reactivo al tiempo te lo que vamos a
obtener es una línea recta ok y además
este punto de aquí la ordenada al origen
es justo la concentración inicial de a y
la pendiente de esta recta
un diente
está pendiente de aquí es igual a menos
la constante de velocidad de la reacción
es igual a menos
y eso es lo que deducimos de la ley de
la velocidad integrada para reacciones
de orden cero y bueno aquí hay que
escribir que este es la concentración
inicial de a como lo tenemos aquí bueno
ahora vamos a pensar acerca de la vida
media y recuerda que la vida media es el
tiempo necesario para que la
concentración de un reactivo se
disminuya a la mitad de la concentración
inicial entonces si tenemos la vida
media que se representa por t un medio y
la queremos sustituir en la ecuación
aquí en el tiempo en ese momento cuando
el tiempo es igual a la vida media la
concentración de a en ese tiempo entre
un medio es igual a la mitad de la
concentración inicial aunque tenemos la
concentración inicial dividida a la
mitad así es que si vamos a sustituir en
esta ecuación el tiempo por la vida
media tenemos que sustituir la
en tracción de y al tiempo de la vida
media por la concentración inicial sobre
dos entonces pues reescribamos lo que
tenemos por aquí tenemos la
concentración inicial de a sobre dos es
igual a menos que por la vida media vida
media más la concentración inicial de a
concentración inicial de a y pues
queremos encontrar la vida media y
entonces vamos a despejar la del lado
izquierdo tenemos un medio de la
concentración inicial y del lado derecho
tenemos uno por la concentración inicial
que si la pasáramos del otro lado
quedaría con un medio menos uno por la
concentración de a entonces por aquí
tenemos un medio de la concentración de
a menos 1 por la concentración de a y
esto junto es menos un medio de la
concentración inicial de a y por aquí lo
que nos queda es que sí
a menos que por la vida media dividimos
entre menos k menos por menos se cancela
y lo que nos queda es que la vida media
es igual a la concentración inicial de a
entre 2 por k y listo esta es la vida
media de una reacción de orden 0 y
observa que para estas reacciones de
orden 0 si aumentamos la concentración
inicial entonces aumenta la vida
mediante ok porque la vida media es
directamente proporcional a la
concentración inicial y bueno para que
quede más claro cómo funciona la vida
media en reacciones de orden cero vamos
a ver un ejemplo
tenemos aquí la descomposición de
amoniaco en nitrógeno e hidrógeno y esta
reacción sucede sobre la superficie de
un catalizador metálico entonces digamos
que estamos utilizando platino a este
ejemplo de aquí le vamos a llamar la
situación 1 y digamos que esta es
nuestra superficie de platino y como
nuestra reacción sucede sobre la
superficie de nuestro catalizador
metálico
entonces las moléculas de amoniaco
tienen que estar en contacto directo
sobre la superficie de platino entonces
dibujemos algunas moléculas de amoniaco
por aquí en contacto directo con la
superficie del platino y recordemos que
se trata de una reacción de orden cero y
entonces la velocidad de la reacción es
igual a la constante de velocidad
por la concentración de amoniaco elevado
a la potencia cero pero cualquier número
elevado a la cero es un 1 y entonces
podemos observar que la velocidad de la
reacción no depende de la concentración
de amoniaco y de hecho este dibujo de
aquí nos ayuda a entender por qué porque
si tuviéramos muchas más moléculas de
amoniaco no vamos a modificar la
velocidad de la reacción porque solo
reaccionen estas moléculas de amoniaco
que están en la superficie del platino
porque la velocidad de la reacción no
cambia porque solo estas moléculas de
aquí que están en contacto con la
superficie de platino son las que pueden
reaccionar así es que aumentamos la
concentración de amoniaco pero no
cambiamos la velocidad de la reacción
porque ésta está en limitada por el
tamaño de la superficie de platino bueno
esa fue la situación 1
ahora vamos con la situación 2 tenemos
por aquí nuestra placa de platino y
también tenemos muchas moléculas de
amoniaco que hay algunas están sobre la
superficie de platino pero hay muchas
otras flotando encima sin tener contacto
con el catalizador metálico porque hay
muchísimas moléculas de amoniaco ok
hemos incrementado muchísimo la
concentración de amoniaco y por lo tanto
como tenemos por aquí con la vida media
si incrementamos la concentración del
reactivo
que en este caso es amoniaco lo que
obtenemos es que la vida media también
incrementa si aumentamos la
concentración de a la vida media también
aumenta y eso tiene todo el sentido del
mundo porque la velocidad de nuestra
reacción es constante no creeis entonces
entre más moléculas tienes más te vas a
tardar en que la mitad de ellas
reaccione si la velocidad es constante
porque aquí tenemos
y sin más moléculas que no están en
contacto con el catalizador metálico
cada momento solo cierta cantidad de
moléculas pueden reaccionar y por lo
tanto entre más moléculas tengas más se
va a tardar en que la mitad de ellas
reaccionen
porque estamos limitados por una
superficie de catalizador metálico y eso
es lo que quería ver en el escenario 2
que si aumentamos la concentración
inicial aumenta la vida media